there was a chance we were gonna see all
three of y'all on on Team me Braun and D
almost had a chance one time but when
you know who was gonna wear number three
are false and why the Rockets should
have be in the Warriors in the playoffs
you know I was one of the toughest
things I think I dealt with what if that
trade was under Lincoln it's even
crazier to think about it now
losing Cove and David Stein man it would
have been it a bit special hey what's up
I'm Chris Paul point guard for the
Oklahoma City Thunder Wake Forest
alumnus North Carolina boy here about to
answer a few questions about myself the
season everything else is going on in
life so yeah about to take it there with
Taylor look okay so first off thank you
for spending your off time here on the
show bowling oh you're stuck with him
today
tell me why you let me run
[Applause]
jihei lines it up right down the pipe
from downtown
well he's supposed to be like the best
are you the best bowler in the NBA I
don't know all right well now it's your
turn to show us you're up first
oh let's see what Shay push-ups here we
go see here we go that's how you do it
crunch time I'm a flex player 21 ain't
got great hair they make you feel old
done sacred you don't make him feel
nothing he naturally just always till
you step on the court
he'd be so happy on my team now I need
gotta guard me know if he would have got
a strike right there this whole
interview thing was over so when we were
bowling Shay jokingly said that you're
old
yeah do you feel old by no means by no
means what is it like being a leader in
the NBA
cuz it's funny you know whenever I do
these interviews I always ask different
guys don't clump anything to get stories
get questions and people absolutely see
you as a leader you're a player people
come to for advice when they just have
questions there's a lot of weight come
with that there's a lot of weight
there's a lot of responsibility but I
think the coolest thing from
is that you know obviously people are
always looking to me for advice or how
can I help them at this point in your
career what's more important plenty your
championship I mean I obviously I want
to win a championship but am I going to
you know what I mean like are you here
doing this for free no I got a family I
got to take care of now when I compete
like I'm competing I always want to win
I'm unbelievably competitive but I got a
lot of great stuff that goes on in my
life and I got two beautiful kids
amazing wife and I got a whole family I
don't go to bed like what a picture of
the trophy I who I gotta have it
I gotta have it but that doesn't mean I
don't want to win it and that I'm not
going strive to win it but is that my
like ultimate goal in life absolutely
not
I got a lasting imprint that I not only
want to try to you know make on others
but my kids
so yeah the NBA championship because all
of my ass like little Chris and Cameron
is my priority that's great okay so if
you could be Commissioner of the NBA for
one day one day you got one day you can
change one on the court rule shoe
probably lower the goals at least for
one quarter how low we go in I mean I
might just need like nine and a half the
game is the game was that other wire
reference huh the game was the game have
you seen the wire
how about seen the wire that's my alias
in a row used to be Avon Barksdale no no
nice string of bills Avon Barksdale
if you could pick one TV world and
you're one fictional character in this
TV world what are you picking the
character that I really really like got
attached to was Jax teller started
watching Sunday on our key and listened
that right there goes like what the why
that's one of the best show watch it
just watch it cuz I mean I didn't think
it was for me yeah but at the end of the
day once you start watching a show it's
about all the stories that's being told
that's what gets you attached to the
show is the characters well on every TV
show every main character they have a
flaw
what's your flock probably better
question for my wife but I mean I got a
lot of I'm probably not very patient
anxious a lot of times show some people
probably say I'm pushy or bossy and all
the different type stuff so I mean I
could run down a whole list for this
interview one thing that comes up is
these articles that talk about you being
a
teamate mmm which I've never heard a
player personally say Chris is the been
teammates I've never heard anything like
that before why do you think that
narrative exists about you some of the
people who say a death may have been
teammates with we did get into it or we
did have a falling out or altercation
and that's it that's that have you ever
wanted to resolve it with it I think so
if that was the case I would more so
like want to know what the issue is I
mean some of them I sort of know what
the issue is but I think I try to
control what I can control you know some
of my teammates like David West who I
played with in New Orleans who it's like
my god forever like we still talk I mean
I play with the Clippers I still talk to
DJ about every day for the JJ reddick
all the time just about all the guys
that I played with there you know I mean
still talk the talk and all these guys
Eric Gordon and all these guys so so
this idea that you just like just like
the Rockets don't ever want to talk to
them again it's awesome when the stuff
happened with the Rockets I just wasn't
happy about how it went down as far as I
know it's a business you got to do what
you got to do but we're adults we can
communicate I just had a conversation
with him a few days before that and he
was like we ain't gonna trade you to the
Oklahoma he asked me do you want to go
there I said no not this one my career
he said all right I won't trade you
there because you chose to come to us
from LA that was that but I mean now owe
me nothing so yeah thankfully everything
happens for a reason
[Applause]
[Music]
okay if you could build like the
ultimate point guard okay you have to
take attributes from different point
guards to build that great one build it
you know I probably want de Rosas
explosiveness and then you got the
different arms so like one one hand
probably like chi reads finishes and all
that and then on the other hand say nice
with the finishes like Steve Nash was a
was a really good shooter rush great
rebounder you know brawn is always good
at passing and all that different eye
stuff but I know like my basketball IQ
and awareness like nobody watches more
basketball you know the main so probably
like D will or Baron Davis is like Bill
shooting also might be somebody like
Gilbert Arenas like Gil see that's what
I'm saying like that's why I get mad
when I'm talking to che and guys like
that cuz that'll be realized on how nice
people like Gil was I'm constantly on
YouTube with che and all that I'm
showing them like this was this was Gil
right here you know the man and that's
why they know that I'm always harping on
defense
cuz the league that we're now guys don't
guard the guy you know what I mean like
this guy is the nicest one on the team
and that guy is supposed to be the nicer
one on the team down guard each other
right don't guard each other and I'm
constantly telling say all the time that
I had to go out there and try to guard
AI I had to try to go try to guard Gil
just cuz it's alright to get us busted
on a given night right I mean he might
drop 35 on you or something like that
but you you'll be better you're learning
we won't watch that moment for you
you're like this is different I think
the first time I played against AI I
think AI might had twenty four shot
attempts in the first half in the first
I just go just going just going you know
the man you like Dan is he gonna pass
you know but that that was that you know
Gil might be six inches taller than me
right and I had to try to learn how to
guard him that's where a lot of my
feistiness comes from that's what I'm
always gonna say about you know on this
night you go at such-and-such
but at the same time guess what I don't
think he can guard you is LeBron James a
point guard bran is unique man and he
can be but at the same time on tomorrow
night he can be a powerful way yeah and
it's so crazy and I mean this when I say
this everybody gets so consumed and
putting them people in a position and
what position they are instead of just
watching and learning you know I mean
like learn how to pass how to rebound
how to make the right play every night
everyone give a damn via point guard
point forward whatever he just he just
nice it's even crazier to think about it
now you know I mean given the situation
in the past few months
losing Cove and David Stein man it would
have been it a bit special you know I
talked about it at some point but me and
Cole but actually got on the phone
talked about you know this and that
yeah my brother was about to get on a
flight to fly to LA
man you know there are times where I'll
be like man that's what this would have
been but you know I can't get caught up
in that it all worked out okay you know
what I'm doing mission for Twitter
because I think I speak for all of
Twitter when I ask you this is there any
chance you will ever see
the Banana Boat crew team up Never Say
Never
you know man I would love that
opportunity it would be fun it'd be
special the road trips you're not I mean
spending that time no no another story
me Braun and D almost had a chance one
time but when you know who was gonna
wear number three but what's the next
question in this universe okay just tell
me this how long ago
sometime in the in the past 15 years to
see Gabrielle Union is actually the one
who was on the banana boat Melo was not
correct Ella was on the vacation yes
Melo was late music questions
you gotta put up who it applies to okay
this is sick who is the worst texture
the worst texture Melo very slow on a
reply okay we had to stay on Melo to
make sure he ain't changed numbers
gives the best advice hang on what
you're talking about okay so for you you
were winning basketball probably
probably bran like life advice sometimes
D way has a little bit of a different
perspective because he's the oldest one
out of all of us not to me he had kids
first you know I mean so I remember I
have little Chris and I was asking him
you know about this about that best
person to be stranded on a deserted
island with stranded on a deserted
island with it's probably bran it's
probably bran and that's because he like
he is like very like routined and like
he knows going on my team or not like
that but you could imagine his locker
like everything is like where it's
supposed to be everything he's very like
he's meticulous very very meticulous and
he's the guy that like as soon as you
get to any location I don't care where
it is he want to know what the Wi-Fi is
he not using like bran not using his
phone no data no he's not using his
phone unless he connected to the Wi-Fi
who's the worst person to be straight
out of deserted island with hmm it might
be mellow you'll know why and this is
why because if you want a deserted
island you would actually at least want
to be able to talk to the other person
that you with you know I'm saying you
want to be trying to figure out how we
gonna get off this island and Mello is
gonna be nowhere to be found
that's my mellow is gonna be nowhere to
be okay who was the worst playlist the
worst playlist probably be way probably
do way because if if you got a playlist
playing he probably gonna play a song
that he didn't
created it's not a thing that D way has
not done what I mean so I'm sure he got
like a few tracks out there or something
like that yeah you could be listening
you could be listening to rowdy rich you
could be listening to Drake J and then
next thing you know D gonna put itself
in there on the thing most likely to get
to the free-throw line most likely to
get to the free-throw line
this one this one cuz he be out there
playing football
absolutely playing football playing
basketball come through running people
over and stuff like that like I mean we
all can sort of do that but Melo does
that too
yeah melot melot and i actually seen
like a clip of that recently or
something like that to say like he got
the most game went so I'm kind of chief
he got the most game winners out of
anybody I think since he came into the
league three all-star team clarified
there was a maybe in the AV team we are
almost played on an all-star team
together I'm down with you
oh that's a strike okay you know you
shoot it and then you just walk on you
hear a lot you gonna be getting ten
push-ups on cause ya ain't over til it's
over
this is it chris is the winner I'm a
second place oh you just did a first
loser and I think I'm on copper push up
rolling in it
yeah I got you one too
hey we're not doing that Christmas but
we like oh we're gonna run that back
once you get nice Oh anyway I let me
walk you out Chris I'm practicing so
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all right true
or false and why
you miss eating bacon
fall oh I think I'm more so miss eating
chicken okay all right chicken wings
hey how's that hello question true or
false and why top black athletes should
start going to HBCUs true true and I'm a
firm believer in that like it hasn't
started somewhere and I know somebody
would be quick to say well you didn't I
think that if kids do go to these HBCUs
that we've seen at the networks or
whatever they're gonna come wherever the
kids go true or false and why the
Rockets should have be in the Warriors
in the playoffs to hell what season ok
bit is last and the year before I wish
we would have mm-hmm but we did and so
you got a move on you know I was one of
the toughest things I think I dealt with
was you know how close you know and then
it didn't happen so gotta get back to
work
I have successfully spent yeah that's a
sick game like I'm gonna use that shits
what it's like you gotta pick one and
it's the end a Y part like that ain't
like just true or false you you asking
why like does that ain't it would you
like the game cuz you know sorry sorry
well thank you for spending so much time
with us who have bowling
I beat che yes you beat me but next time
it's not gonna be that way all right
thank you so much so good to see you bye
hey guys it's Taylor Oaks thank you so
much for watching my show take it there
but now that means you have to subscribe
to the YouTube channel you don't want to
miss all the fun stuff or the next
interview so hit that subscribe button
thanks so much see you soon